ça calme maintenant chantal lauby alain
chabat et dominique poggia
allez lille avec tout ce soir
pour l'intégrer de le alors les rues
viendront pour youtube un vous avez
choisi l'émission de marc olivier fogiel
par erreur et je sais pas et il avait
commencé
il avait commencé son interview par une
question que je vais à nouveau vous vous
posez ce n'est pas qu'on commence par
leurs excuses par une question que je
vais à nouveau vous poser cette année
jean marie bigard va faire le stade de
france ça vous brancherait vous de faire
le stade de france il a répondu je
songeais les réponses de l'époque nazie
oui ben t'as dit si bien sûr aussi bien
sûr chantal a dit ah ouais ah ouais
l'époque j'étais petit mais la question
vous avez choisi si si et quand même
quand même c'est pas nouvelles réponses
a quand même pour chantal emmène alors
est ce que le fait d'avoir fait
d'intégrer un élan avoir vendu un
million a joué dans le fait de faire
intégrer le 2 non ce qu'on voulait
c'était surtout faire un geste auprès du
public un geste de générosité ordonnée
du bonheur d'accord mais c'est réussi
évidemment
qui fait drôle un peu maintenant c'est
pour voir des bonnes émissions de canal
on est obligé d'acheter des dvd donc
c'est sûr c'est un peu plus compliqué
qu'avant mais on peut y arriver quoi je
m'inscris en faux
vous avez la nostalgie des années canal
chantal non non non c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque j'en prenais pas de drogue ont
été virés mois ci non non moi j'ai tenu
oui c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont alors c'est
vrai qu'il est député à tous les étages
et canal en tout cas au nom d'al veine
de dire à la tenait pas mieux
pierre lescure se promener à poil dans
les couloirs c'est vrai il était très à
la retombée 1
c'est la forme d'une herbe comme le bois
c'est la réplique du village
l'appel est votre nouveau dvd s'appelle
la férule 2 pourquoi pas eu lui un chu
du jeune tu lui but où dominent écuries
du mais on y avait pensé et du findel
mieux on sait d'où l'année prochaine non
non non non on avait fini la bouteille
de vin blanc
alors pour noël dans lequel il ya le
double dvd soit le double dvd soit le
coffret 4 dvd édition limitée collector
est magnifique mais jusqu à l'intérieur
on a non seulement l'intégrisme le livre
des nuls plus tvn 595 plus toute
l'histoire de la télévision l'intégrale
si l'on verra sur les quinze jours nous
vous offrons
il faut laisser me suis donc en avant
regardez à quoi ça ressemble vous allez
aussi de regarder tous les trois votre
caméra et dire ensemble mais celle là
celui d'avant le chanteur celle là
l'allemagne est à la search 1 à 2 3